i have been in it industry for nine plus
years now after completing my mca in
2012 i started my career as a software
tester in a mid-level organization i
switched several organization until i
got the first big breakthrough with
cognizant in 2019 as a product test
specialist after completion of my
selenium 3.0 certification with
simplyland currently i'm working at my
dream company accenture as a qa test
lead
hi my name is sunit roy i live in
kolkata with my wife daughter and
parents my main expertise is in
functional and automation testing using
selenium java i have good exposure to
designing test cases test plan and
executing them i am also well versed
with project and test management tool
like tfs rally jira hplm and conference
i have extended work experience and
knowledge of the agile scrum model the
competition in the iit industry is fears
and as the technology keeps on changing
rapidly one must be up to date with the
changes happening regularly one must
keep up skilling to be at par with the
market so i decided to upskill myself it
was really a turning point in my career
the course helped me to improve my
knowledge and get a clear understanding
of the automation skill set to clear
interview and get industry ready
i browse through many website which i
found on google but finally i choose
simply learn
my experience was fabulous with the
virtual live classes the detailed
explanation of each topic the doubt
clearing session and the real-time demo
projects were as per industry standards
and were remarkable i also learned
agilent's crown methodologies during the
course and plan to improve those skills
to move to project management position
in the near future in the technical
aspect or scrum master to get the
designation of a technical manager as a
working professional i would like to
give advice to all the young minds who
are getting in it if you are passionate
about something and just work hard you
will definitely be successful because
luck papers the one who works hard and
keep at it stay safe and keep up skills
[Music]